it's once before E5 G3 okay avoiding
avoiding okay this is a possible move 93
is of course the main move
C6 that's the downside of G3 we're
playing D5 and D4
Bishop before check and here Magnus
Carson stats whereas Knight C3 could
very easily be a surprise but yeah
Indian Madness goes with uh yeah 93
would remind as well like starting with
D4 c496 registry it doesn't bring back
good memories I would say nice is
replayed by Magnus car said okay we're
serious throw throw development I mean
it's very personal game 93.9 F6 he
didn't go Bishop G2 e uh E3 he went E4
immediately what's uh
the verbs I don't know
oh that's very that's very I don't know
how to describe it but uh yeah that's so
Bishop B7 my first instinct is to go uh
d45 yeah absolutely yeah exactly yeah
the bishop is now misplaced and uh D5 if
you go if you go visual Basics now I
will probably wait be wait empty before
even I'm not natural but uh yeah
actually I killed your Bishop so I'll
shift something yeah Bishop B7 finally
is the choice for
hurry oh hurry Yeah
Yeah from what we've seen
I I think castles in 95 is likelier than
the other line but
I think it will come quickly actually
um I'm not sure she played many games
but he took one before first right we
uh we were trying to do it we were
trying to play 95 straight away but he
included this because
I mean I wasn't really against the idea
of not giving black a chance to trade
more thesis uh but yeah it's become very
very sharp because after takes takes
Queen B6 uh Rook days a GG and here
madness has basically his position has
one problem
and it is that the iPhone 2 has no moves
and he solves it in a very very
instructive manner because I think it's
a move until you see somebody do this
it's a move that might not really occur
to you but but you do have to understand
that this exists in all kinds of
positions like this where you just need
to give this nine squares I can actually
I mean with your pieces so far on the
king side I'm I'm looking at all kinds
of strange things here but like I say so
yeah or here yeah but once again I my I
I thought about this and then I realized
The Rook indeed is protected so after
let's say even after HG Queen G5 this is
not a double attack it's just an attack
so you can play Knight of fate or
something and like what am I doing with
my life I thought it was a double attack
there for a second but it really isn't
and he played 94 immediately and Knight
F6 came takes takes
and hook C5 makes a lot of sense
protecting here I just want to take that
pawn of course Queen before as we saw it
speed up previously Queen takes before
Bishop D5 was a doll so it's been C5
protecting is spawn now Queen B6
protecting the bone and asking a
question so Queen is three I think Queen
Street starting with C8 suddenly
um
if H5 let's say C8
we are probably quite happy about taking
only five on the end of those lines yeah
yeah because after now oxyh has this
small uh intermediate check and now you
can take okay you have to come back with
a hook but it's not ideal
now played very quickly by Magnus Carson
and he wants to play Roxy 7 when B6 H5
H6
okay he is doing this uh this stuff yeah
if I can start wouldn't player six F6
would have been on the ball I'm pretty
sure
yeah uh age 623 it feels like we're
making the king-size
really does feel like something might
happen to your king side right yeah nice
King side you got there shame it if
anything would happen to it like Rook C1
sorry Rook C8 Queen A1 Rook C1 and then
take on H6 Ah that's clever and then
what what's the point what's the point
I'm not sure Queen's xh6 Queen takes H6
excuse me HG I wish before Oh that's
hang on but foreign
oh that's very possible to miss
and now we are we are taking the famous
mechanism let's say uh if you've got B3
we'll show it one more time
hop hop hop hop
that is a big big threat and of course
on Bishop D5 is covering F7 which is
nice actually we can win even easier I
mean that's it's just what was the
option oh my evaluation I don't know
what was the option but Queen H6 looks
like a very good move and now High
Krishna realizing probably but
yeah his choices are kind of unfortunate
here you can continue trying not to play
that end game which probably is just
lost you have to assume that that ending
uh down in pieces uh eventually lost if
white plays technically precisely and
magnus's
generally quite quite good at precise
technique of course he will get pinned
by the war Champion will go kudito just
did and
and they will play this position it
really is the best choice he has I'm
really I'm actually very very curious to
see if Magnus will take his uh
with the queen or with a bishop on D5
and he will go he will go Queen takes
now and yeah I think I think he was
quite happily going to take with the
queen I think it feels like this should
be winning yes you are slightly nervous
because there's only two pawns left but
it feels like
you know the black king is still on this
like on G8 it's not on G4
so you you have to assume this is and he
wants to play already so he doesn't have
any
they came with the queen very quickly
wow I mean if you had some time to
assess these things so I mean he clearly
came to the conclusion that black is not
fast enough okay I think it's the I'm
still impressed by the speed but yeah
yeah
okay same technique same technique wow
yeah
it's gone Bishop C6 but
it's all very very similar
um so King E5 King G3 oh no King if I
actually was a bishop on six we can go
King G5 because we are no longer afraid
of any of those two three this is why he
chose this square of course it's very
clever yeah this is very clever by
Magnus I'm a bit curious to see this
movie Breaking E5 and the amount
looking things will things will start
falling apart here
the the kind of a scenario where Blake
maybe makes a draw is like King D4 here
I think thanks to 5e3 we take everything
we take on G4 and black goes B3 this
might be a draw actually right because1
and you're slightly worse in that end
game but you're probably not going to
lose it yeah Magnus wins uh Magnus wins
what was retrosy at the end of the game
ah exactly exactly what we said yeah
King takes F5 he played B3 of course
he's not
I mean you have to make small uh
more complicated tricks